The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
W
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: In the
last lecture, we
considered the frequency
response of linear shift
and variance systems.
In this lecture, what
I would like to do
is extend some of those ideas
to the notion of the Fourier
transform, which I'll refer to
as the discrete time Fourier
transform.
So let me begin by
reminding you of one
of the key results
from last time,
namely, the notion
of the frequency
response of a linear
shift invariant system.
For a linear shift
invariant system,
we saw last time that
one of the key properties
was that for a complex
exponential input,
the output is a complex
exponential sequence
with the same complex frequency,
but with a change in amplitude.
And the change in
amplitude, that
is the function h
of e to the j omega,
we refer to as the frequency
response of the system.
The expression that we had
for the frequency response,
in terms of the unit
sample response,
was that the frequency
response h of e to the j omega,
is given by the sum of
h of n, the unit sample
response of the system,
multiplied by e to the minus j
omega n.
So this is a relationship
that tells us,
in terms of the unit sample
response of the system,
how to get the
frequency response.
There were two properties
of the frequency response
that I stressed last time.
One of them was the fact
that the frequency response
is a function of a
continuous variable, omega.
That is, complex
exponential inputs
can have the frequency variable
omega, vary continuously.
Omega is a continuous
variable, whereas n
is the discrete variable.
So this was one
important property.
The second important property is
that the frequency response is
a periodic function of omega.
And the period is equal 2 pi.
H of e to the j omega
is equal to h of e
to the j omega plus 2 pi
k, where k is any integer.
Now one of the sort of heuristic
explanations or justifications
for why the frequency
response is periodic,
as I've tried to indicate
in several lectures,
is basically tied to the fact
that complex exponentials
or sinusoidal inputs, are very
periodically with frequency
over an interval 0 to 2 pi.
That is, once we've looked at
them for omega between 0 and 2
pi, if we go further
than that in frequency,
all we see are the same
complex exponentials
or the same
sinusoids over again.
So that, in essence,
is the reason
why the frequency response is
a periodic function of omega.
Well, one of the
things we'd like to do
is develop an
inverse relationship,
which permits us to get
the unit sample response
from the frequency response.
One heuristic notion
or style of developing
such an inverse
relationship, we can
get by observing that since
the frequency response is
a function of a
continuous variable omega,
and in fact, it's a
periodic function of omega,
then it should have a Fourier
series representation.
That is, it's a continuous
periodic function.
A continuous periodic
function has a Fourier series
representation.
Well in fact, if we
look at this expression,
we see that indeed what
this is is a Fourier series
expansion of this
periodic function in terms
of a complex Fourier series.
The Fourier series expressed in
terms of complex exponentials.
Well, what are the Fourier
series coefficients?
The Fourier series
coefficients are the values
of the unit sample response, in
other words, the values h of n.
So in fact, this has the
form of a Fourier series.
That means that these are
the Fourier coefficients.
That means that we can get these
Fourier coefficients in terms
of h of e to the j
omega, the way we always
get Fourier series
coefficients in terms
of a periodic
continuous function.
Well, the resulting
expression then
is that the Fourier series
coefficients, or equivalently
the unit sample response,
is equal to 1 over 2 pi
times the integral over
a period, which I've
taken as minus pi to plus
pi, of h of e to the j omega,
e to the omega n, d omega.
This is just simply
the expression
for Fourier series
coefficients in terms
of the continuous
periodic function
that we're dealing with.
Well that's, in a sense,
a heuristic derivation.
We can in fact verify that
this expression is valid simply
by substituting in to the
integral, the expression for h
of e to the j omega.
And if we do that,
we end up with,
for the expression for
h of e to the j omega,
we have the sum of h of k,
e to the minus j omega k.
Substituting in, the
result is this integral.
If we interchange the order
of summation and integration,
then the resulting
expression is shown here.
And we can observe
that this integral--
First of all, let's consider
it for n not equal to k.
If n is not equal to k, this
is just simply the integral
over a period of 2 pi
of a complex exponential
whose period is 2 pi.
The integral of the real
part is the integral
of a cosine over an
integral number of periods.
And the integral of
the imaginary part
is the integral of the sine over
an integral number of periods.
Obviously then, this integral,
if n is not equal to k
is going to be 0.
So for n not equal to k,
the value of this integral
is 0, whereas for n equal
to k, this exponent is 0,
the exponential is unity, unity
integrated from minus pi to pi
is equal to 2 pi.
So for n equal to k, the
value of the integral
is equal to 2 pi.
Well that means that the
only term in this sum that
is going to contribute to
the answer is the term for k
equal to n, because for all
the others the integral is 0.
So for k equal to n, that's
the only non-zero term, for k
equal to n, the value
of this integral
is 2 pi, which will cancel
out this 1 over 2 pi
and consequently we get h of n.
All right, so this is, in a
sense, a formal justification
for the fact that, indeed this
is the inverse relationship
to express h of n terms
of the frequency response.
Although, in fact it's more
useful in terms of insight
to think of it as
the Fourier series
coefficients of a function,
a periodic function,
of the continuous
variable omega.
Now this in essence, is a
Fourier domain representation
for the unit sample
response of a system.
And in fact, we can think of
this as a Fourier transform
or a time domain, Fourier
domain transform pair,
relating the unit sample
response of a system
and the frequency
response of the system.
And we can go back and forth.
Now one of the obvious
facts is that any sequence,
if we wanted to, we could
think of as the unit sample
response of a system.
Well, that suggests then
that this transform pair
isn't restricted
to just sequences
that we explicitly
identify as the unit sample
response of a system.
It in fact permits the
representation of an arbitrary,
not quite arbitrary as
we'll see in a while,
but the representation of a
more general class of sequences
than just the ones
that we explicitly
identify as the unit sample
response of a system.
That is, we can generalize
this set of ideas
to the Fourier transform,
which is a frequency domain
representation of an arbitrary,
again not quite arbitrary,
but for the time being we'll
consider arbitrary sequence,
x of n.
Well, the Fourier transform
then is defined as x of e
to the j omega, which
is the sum of x of n, e
to the minus j omega n, the
Fourier transform x of e
to the j omega, of
a sequence, x of n,
is essentially the frequency
response of a system whose
unit sample response
would be x of n.
So then obviously from what
we just finished discussing,
we have an inverse relationship
that tells us what x of n
is in terms of x of
e to the j omega.
And that then is
this relationship.
Well this then provides a
transform pair, or a frequency
domain, time domain
relationship between sequences
and frequency domain functions.
And it's useful, in fact,
to interpret this expression
somewhat heuristically again
as basically corresponding
to a decomposition of
a sequence, x of n,
in terms of complex exponentials
with incremental amplitude.
This is basically an expression
that says that x of n is a sum,
except that it's sum sort of
in the limit which corresponds
to an integral, of a set
of complex exponentials
with amplitudes
that are essentially
given by the Fourier transform
x of e to the j omega.
Well in fact, you can see
this a little more explicitly
if we consider this integral
as the limiting form
of a sum, the limit,
as delta omega goes
to 0, of the sum of x of
e to the j k delta omega,
times delta omega over 2 pi,
e to the j k delta omega n.
This limit is by definition,
what this integral is.
So an important
point to keep in mind
is that basically the
Fourier transform corresponds
to a decomposition of
a sequence in terms
of a linear combination
of complex exponentials
with incremental amplitudes.
There are a number
of reasons why that's
an important point of view.
One of the reasons
is that it leads
to a very important property
of linear shift invariance
systems, which I refer to
as the convolution property,
and which states that if I
have the convolution of two
sequences, x of n and y
of n, then the Fourier
transform of those is the
product of their Fourier
transforms.
And this of course, shouldn't
be an h, it should be a y.
Or this shouldn't be a
y, it should be an h.
The important property is
that the convolution of two
sequences has, as its
Fourier transform,
the product of the
Fourier transforms.
Well let's look at again,
somewhat heuristically,
an argument that
at least justifies
this, keeping in mind that
we could go through this more
formally, plugging sums
into integrals and integrals
into sums, but
let's not do that.
Let's look at this from a
somewhat heuristic point
of view.
First of all, we
have that again,
a property that we
began the lecture with,
that for a linear
shift invariant system,
a complex exponential
input gives us
at the output, the same
complex exponential, that
is the same frequency,
and only one
of them, multiplied by
h of e to the j omega 0.
That's a consequence of
linearity and shift invariance.
We know also, that because of
the fact that the system is
linear, if we have
a linear combination
of complex exponentials, then
the output of this system
is going to be the
same linear combination
of complex exponentials, with
the amplitudes multiplied
by h of e to the j omega k.
In other words, each
of these exponentials
has as an output ase of k times
h of e to the j omegus of k, e
to the j omegus of k n.
A sum of those at
the input gives us
a sum at the output
because of the fact
that the system is linear.
All right, so let's
take an input, which
is an arbitrary input, more
or less arbitrary, an input
x of n, which I can express in
terms of its Fourier transform,
in terms of this inverse
Fourier transform relationship.
All right, now m as I
emphasized just a minute ago,
is a decomposition of x of
n as a linear combination
of complex exponentials.
This is a linear combination
of complex exponentials
at the input, so
what's the output?
Well, the output is then going
to be a linear combination
of complex exponentials
with the amplitude
of each one of the
input exponentials,
multiplied by the frequency
response of the system
at that frequency.
So the result is that with
this as the input, what
we have to get at
the output is this,
the same linear
combination, the only change
being that the complex
amplitudes of the input
are multiplied by h
of e to the j omega.
Well, this of course, is the
expression for the output.
We put in x of n, we know
that we're getting out y of n.
So obviously this then must
be the Fourier transform
of the output of the system.
So what this says then
is that the Fourier
transform of the output y of e
to the j omega, has to be this,
it has to be x of e to
the j omega times h of e
to the j omega.
And basically-- well, and
we know also that y of n
is going to be equal to x
of n convolved with h of n.
So basically, this justifies
the convolution property, that
is the convolution
of two sequences
has as its Fourier transform,
the product of the Fourier
transform of each of the
individual sequences.
Very important property.
And although we can go through
a formal derivation of this,
in fact the basic reason for
it is tied to the arguments
that I've outlined here.
And in terms of insight,
I feel that it's
more important to understand
this way of looking at it
than to understand
a formal derivation.
Well, this is interesting,
also important,
and also should be familiar
to you in terms of things
that you're used
to thinking about
for continuous time systems.
Obviously, in
continuous time systems
the same type of property holds.
That is, that the
Fourier transform changes
convolution to multiplication.
And in fact, it permits the
description of a linear shift
invariant system to be in
terms of multiplication
rather than in terms
of convolution.
And as we'll see in
a number of lectures,
that basically the basis
for the notions of filtering
and some other very
important notions,
and notions of modulation etc.
OK, key property,
this is a key property
of linear shift invariant
systems and the Fourier
transform.
There are, of course,
lots of other properties
of linear shift
invariant systems--
sorry, other
properties, there are
other properties, obviously, of
linear shift invariant systems.
There are other properties
of Fourier transforms that
are important, both in terms of
interpreting Fourier transforms
and in terms of computing
Fourier transforms
of a variety of sequences.
A lot of these properties
will be developed in the text
and also in the study
guide, so you'll
have to do the work
rather than me.
But let me just indicate one
class of properties that,
again, should be
very familiar to you
if you relate your thinking
back to continuous time
Fourier transforms.
And that is the class
of symmetry properties
for the special case in which
the sequences that we're
talking about are
real sequences.
Well the basic symmetry
property is that for x of n
real the Fourier transform is
a conjugate symmetric function,
x of e to the j omega is
equal to x conjugate of e
to the minus j omega.
And we can see that,
essentially in a straightforward
way, that is the derivation is
effectively straightforward.
Here's x of e to the j
omega, the sum of x of n, e
to the minus j omega n.
Here is x of e to
the minus j omega.
Well, the only difference
between that and that
is that we replace
omega by minus omega,
so this becomes a plus sign.
Of course, it's not this that
we want from this expression,
it's the conjugate of that.
So we want to complex
conjugate this.
Well, we will do the same
on the left--hand side--
on the right-hand side.
And so we would conjugate
that and conjugate
this, which replaces this
plus sign with a minus sign.
But we're talking about
a real sequence, x of n,
so x conjugate of
n is just x of n.
In other words, this is just
the x of an all over again.
And so we have that x conjugate
of e to the minus j omega
is the sum of x of
n, e to the minus j
omega n, which is just
what we have up here.
So obviously then,
these two are equal.
So for a real sequence,
the Fourier transform
is a conjugate
symmetric function.
This is what we'll call
conjugate symmetric.
Well let's press that
a little further.
We have x of e to
the j omega, which
I can represent in
terms of its real part
and its imaginary part as
obviously x real, x sub r of e
to the j omega, plus j times
x sub i of e to the j omega.
And the conjugate
symmetric counterpart
is this with omega replaced by
minus omega and the expression
conjugated.
So we have x sub r of
e to the minus j omega,
minus j times x sub i of
e to the minus j omega.
And we know that
these two are equal.
Well, if these two are
equal, then these two
are equal, and so are these.
The real part of x
of e to the j omega
must be equal to the real part
of x of e to the minus j omega.
In other words,
the real part has
to be the same if omega is
replaced by minus omega.
That means then that the real
part of the Fourier transform
is an even function of omega.
Meaning that if we replace
omega by minus omega
then the real part
doesn't change.
The imaginary part, on
the other hand, does.
In particular, on the basis
of what we're saying here
and the equality of these, the
imaginary part x sub i of e
to the j omega, must
be equal to minus,
don't forget the minus
sign, minus x sub i of e
to the minus j omega.
And that says then, that if we
replace omega by minus omega,
then the sign of the
imaginary part changes.
So the imaginary part, in fact,
is an odd function of omega.
The real part is an
even function of omega.
Well, from this,
or from this, we
can also show that the magnitude
of the Fourier transform
is an even function of omega.
And the angle of the
Fourier transform
is an odd function of omega.
And those, of course,
are identical to what
we know is true for the
continuous time Fourier
transform.
Remember however, again, that
these are periodic functions,
whereas in the continuous
time case, they're not.
All right well, this
is an introduction
to the Fourier transform.
One of the things
that we've refrained
from doing in all
of these lectures
is tying our
development too closely
to the notion of continuous
time signals, and in particular,
avoiding to some
extent, the notion
of interpreting discrete time
signals as just simply sampled
replicas of continuous
time signals.
And we'll continue to do
that throughout this set
of lectures.
But in particular
Fourier transform,
I think that it's
instructive to tie together,
at least in terms
of some insight
into the relationship, the
continuous time Fourier
transform of obviously
continuous time signal,
and the discrete time Fourier
transform for a sequence that's
obtained by periodic sampling.
That is, equally spaced sampling
of the continuous time signal.
So what I'd like to do now is
focus on that relationship,
emphasizing again, that
not all sequences arise
by periodic sampling of
continuous time signals.
But for the cases
in which they do,
the relationship between
the continuous time
and discrete time Fourier
transform is instructive.
So let's take a look
at the relationship
between some continuous time
and discrete time Fourier
transforms when we obtain
the discrete time signal
by sampling a
continuous time signal.
Well, we begin of course,
with a continuous time,
time function which I denote by
x sub a of t, a sort of meaning
analog.
And the steps that
we would go through
to convert that to a
sequence are first of all,
to go through a sampler,
which I've indicated here.
And the output of the sampler is
then a sampled continuous time
version of this signal.
This essentially
is the input signal
multiplied by an impulse train.
So I've indicated
that here, here's
the continuous time input.
Here is the
continuous time output
of the sampler,
which is an impulse
train with the envelope
of the impulse train
being the continuous time
function x sub a of t.
All right, well this
isn't the sequence.
This is just simply
an impulse train.
To turn this into
a sequence we need
to go into a box,
which I've labeled
c slash d, meaning continuous
time to discrete time
converter.
And the output then
is a sequence x of n.
The sequence values being
samples of x sub a of t
at the sampling
instances n times capital
T. In other words,
it's converting
the areas of these impulses
into sequence values.
Now I've illustrated it here
for one choice for the sampling
interval capital T.
Let's, down here,
illustrate it for a sampling
interval that's twice as long.
Well, of course we have the
same continuous time input.
The sampled output,
x sub a, tilde of t,
has the same envelope, but
the spacing of the impulses
is twice what it is here,
and that I've indicated.
The envelope, of
course, is the same.
But at the output of
the continuous time
to discrete time
converter, what do we have?
Well, we have the areas
of these impulses lined up
along this axis, again,
at integer values of n.
That is, the spacing
of the lines,
when we look at
the sequence here,
must be exactly the same as
the spacing of the lines here,
it's just that the values are
different because we picked out
samples at different instance.
So in fact, the
envelope here is indeed
a compressed version of the
envelope that we had here.
Very important point.
The point being that no matter
what the sampling rate is
the sequence values, when we
line them up as a sequence,
are going to fall at integer
values along this argument,
n, always at intervals
that correspond to 1.
Whereas the output
of the sampler
had impulses occurring at a
spacing of capital T, which
in this case, was capital
T 1, and in this case
is capital T 2.
All right well,
this is essentially
the sampling process plus the
conversion to a discrete time
signal.
And now let's take
a look at what this
means in terms of the Fourier
transform of the discrete time
signal as compared with
the Fourier transform
of the continuous time signal.
Let's do this in two steps.
First of all, we
have the sampler.
Here is the input x sub a of
t, continuous time function.
Here is the output, x sub a
tilde of t, a continuous time
function.
And the output of the
sampler is the input
to the sampler, multiplied
by an impulse train.
Or equivalently,
it's an impulse train
with the areas of
the impulses given
by the values of x sub
a of t at the times
that the impulses occur.
Naught, by the way, is what
I'm using as the notation
to designate a unit impulse,
unit continuous time impulse.
Now in the Fourier
transformed domain then,
the continuous time
Fourier transform,
is the convolution of
the continuous time
Fourier transform
of x sub a of t,
convolved with the Fourier
transform of the impulse train,
which is an impulse train
in the frequency domain.
That's a result
that you should be
familiar with for
continuous time signals.
Or equivalently, it's
given by 1 over t,
times the sum of x
sub a of j omega,
plus j 2 pi r over capital
T. Basically, what that means
is that the Fourier transform
of this continuous time signal
is equal to the
Fourier transform
of this continuous time signal,
but repeated over and over
again in frequency at intervals
of 2 pi over capital T.
So this is sort of a standard
sampling theorem kind of result
in the continuous time
case, and a result
that you should be more
or less familiar with.
Let's look at this now from
a different point of view.
Again looking at x sub
a tilde of j omega.
Well x sub a tilde of
j omega is the integral
of x sub a tilde of t, e
to the minus j omega t d t.
Substitute in for
x sub a tilde of t,
the relationship in terms
of an impulse train,
and interchange summation
and integration,
and I think you could verify
in a very straightforward way
that what you end up with is
an expression for the Fourier
transform at the
output of the sampler
as given by the sampling
values times e to the minus j n
capital omega T. Capital omega
is a continuous frequency
variable.
Now we want to look
at the relationship
between the Fourier transform,
continuous time of x sub a of t
and the discrete time
Fourier transform of x of n.
So we have the
next step, which is
to put this impulse train into
the continuous to discrete time
converter.
And I remind you that we
just developed two results.
One result was that x
sub a tilde of j omega
was given by this expression.
Also we developed that it
Well what's the
Fourier transform
of the output of the continuous
to discrete time converter?
Well, it's just simply
x of e to the j omega,
our discrete time
Fourier transform,
which is equal to the
sum on n of x of n.
But x of n is x sub a of n
capital T. So we have x sub a
of n capital T, times e
to the minus j omega n.
Well let's compare
this with this.
We see that they're exactly
the same except that for omega,
little omega here we
have capital omega times
capital T there.
Consequently, we can say that
the discrete time Fourier
transform is equal
to the Fourier
transform of the impulse train,
the continuous time Fourier
with omega times capital T
equal to little omega.
And we had another expression
for the Fourier transform
of the impulse train,
which we derived here.
Consequently, the final
result that we end up with
is that the Fourier transform
of the discrete time sequence
is equal to 1 over t times
the sum of x sub a of j omega,
plus j 2 pi r over capital
T, with omega replaced
by little omega, divided by
capital T. In other words,
we had the expression that
capital omega times capital T
is equal to little omega.
And this then tells us
what the Fourier transform
of the sequence is in
terms of the Fourier
transform of the output.
Well, this is just
the equations.
Let's take a look at what
this looks like graphically.
I've depicted here
the continuous time
Fourier transform of
some time function,
and I picked the
Fourier transform
that looks like a triangle.
Well, first of all
we derived the fact
that the impulse
train that results
from sampling
little x sub a of t
has a Fourier transform, which
is this, periodically repeated
in frequency with a period in
frequency equal to 2 pi divided
by capital 1, where capital
1 is the sampling rate.
And on the basis
of the expression
that we derived relating the
discrete time Fourier transform
and the continuous
time Fourier transform,
the discrete time
Fourier transform
looks exactly like this,
but with a re-normalization
of the frequency axis, because
capital omega times capital T
is equal to little omega.
Yes, capital omega times capital
T is equal to little omega.
So where capital omega is
equal to 2 pi over capital T,
little omega is equal to 2 pi.
So this point, which
was at pi over capital T
ends up on the omega,
little omega axis at pi.
So this picture just simply
gets scaled according
to the relationship that
capital omega times capital T
is equal to little omega.
Well, this is, for one choice
of the sampling period.
Obviously, if
capital T was large
enough so that 2 pi over
t 1 was small enough,
then each of these individual
replicas of the frequency
response would interact.
And we wouldn't have just
the simple separation
of the spectra as we have here.
We'd have an interaction,
which of course, is
the interaction and the
relationship between when
that interaction
occurs and capital T,
is the basis for the well-known,
and hopefully, theorem
that you're familiar with
namely, the sampling theorem.
Well, to illustrate that if we
had a different sampling rate,
say twice the sampling rate
that we have over here,
so that capital T is
equal to 2 times capital
T 1, then starting with the same
continuous time spectrum, what
we have now is the spectra,
again periodically repeated,
with a period again, which
is 2 pi over capital T,
which in this case is
2 pi over capital T 2,
but now they interact
and of course, we
have to add these up.
That was the expression
that we just derived.
So in that case, we get some
interaction or aliasing,
as it's referred to.
And due to this
aliasing, the periodic,
one period of this
periodic spectrum
no longer resembles
the original spectrum.
This is the Fourier transform
for the sampled continuous time
function.
That is, this is the
Fourier transform
for the impulse train.
And now if we renormalizing
the frequency axis
so that we express this in terms
of the discrete time frequency
variable, little omega, then
we simply scale this picture
so that we end up with
2 pi over capital T,
corresponding to 2
pi in little omega.
Pi over capital T
corresponding to pi.
And we see in fact, as--
we better see, that is, it
better turn out this way,
that the spectrum in
the discrete time case
is a periodic function of omega.
In other words, it's periodic.
Furthermore, the period
is given by 2 pi,
whereas here the period was
2 pi divided by capital T.
All right, this perhaps
takes a little digesting.
And you'll have
some chance to do
that as we work some problems.
We, meaning you, as
you work some problems
in the study guide and
digest this a little
while you're reading the text.
But it's an important
relationship
and it's important
to understand it.
Now, this is basically
the Fourier transform,
the relationship between
the discrete time
and continuous time
Fourier transform.
One of the difficulties
with the Fourier transform,
which I've avoided illustrating
explicitly in this lecture,
is that the Fourier
transform doesn't
exist for all sequences.
In particular, it doesn't
converge for all sequences.
And this is a problem
which we can get around
by generalizing the
notion of the Fourier
transform to what we'll
call the z transform.
And the z transform,
as you'll observe,
is like, in the continuous time
case, the Laplace transform.
And this is what we'll go
on to in the next lecture.
Thanks
[MUSIC PLAYING]